que georges amélie chercher au global
policy institute c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur
[Musique]
georges jammet liban soir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
en syrie l'union européenne met en garde
contre un affrontement entre forces
turques et russes que pas l'europe dans
ce dossier était l'audible où il s'agit
plutôt d'une déclaration symbolique
selon vous que les européens ne peuvent
pas faire grand chose
le véritable la véritable question c'est
combien de temps erdogan peut-il
continuer à insister dans sa posture qui
n'est pas viable n'est pas en conformité
avec les accords de sotchi et il a été
répété à plusieurs reprises par les
russes que le minimum auquel il
s'attendait de la part de la turquie
c'est qu'il y aurait une désescalade
aucune attaque contre les forces russes
ou syrienne il n'a pas respecté cela il
a promis qu'il se débarrasserait des
combattants d'al-qaïda et lead et il ne
l'a pas fait et maintenant il se plaint
se plaint parce qu'il perd sa position à
être les façons sa position n'était pas
tenable ne peut donner aucune raison
pour le maintien de ces postes à église
lorsqu'il était dans le nord-est il
pouvait dire et bien gacé force du pkk
et il y avait qui représentait une
menace sécuritaire pour la turquie mais
quelle raison at il des travellings et
pourtant il continue à dire nous le
devons y rester car je suis fortement
préoccupés par la possibilité d'un
afflux de réfugiés vers la turquie
oui effectivement la turquie a un
problème de réfugiés
mais le problème est dû à cette action
irraisonnée de la turquie lors de la
guerre en syrie est aujourd'hui elle
refuse de mettre un terme à cette guerre
est-ce que selon vous on pourrait
craindre une nouvelle escalade des
tensions après l'ultimatum de recep
tayyip erdogan
ouais désormais on peut craindre une
escalade mais j'aurais tendance à penser
que erdogan fait plus de bruit que qu'il
ne peut commettre de dégâts nous avons
déjà eu l'expérience de ses
fanfaronnades par exemple en 2015 il a
détruit un avion en pensant n'avions
russe en pensant que l'otan viendra se
sont courts mais le temps lui a dit et
non débrouillez vous donc
recep tayyip erdogan a dû faire machine
arrière et s'incliner devant la turquie
avec beaucoup de sécurité devant la
russie nous ne connaissons pas
exactement la force de la turquie il ya
eu un coup d'état avorté en russie en
turquie rassam à erdogan a purgé son
armée donc pour moi on peut être très
sceptique quant à la possibilité de la
turquie en matière militaire
donc notamment s'il s'agit d'affronter
les russes il dit qu'il va riposter
contre la syrie mais comment la russie
ne va pas ouvrir l'espace aérien syrien
pour la turquie et toute tentative
d'erdogan de l'utiliser
ces avions pour frapper des positions
syrienne en syrie sera empêchée par à la
russie erdogan a t'il vraiment
l'intention de se lancer dans l'
escalade
je le pense pas d'où la cas est ce que
moscou peut encore apaiser les tensions
encore jouer les arbitres selon vous
poser sa b2 je le pense que c'est
raisonnable vis-à-vis des airs de galop
moscou a essayé de répondre à ses
inquiétudes concernant les combattants
du pkk dans le nord-est de la syrie
là la russie a aidé à permettre dès
patrol dans cette région afin d'éliminer
ces combattants elle a essayé de
coopérer avec r2 gagnent avec le
processus de paix d'astana elle a signé
l'accord de sotchi les russes peuvent se
présenter comme étant des arbitres
authentique
ils ont pris au sérieux les
préoccupations sécuritaires turques mais
matin ils peuvent dire effectivement ça
suffit vous êtes à est libre depuis très
longtemps il n'y a aucune bonne raison
pour que vous y restent y est il faut
bien que cette guerre touche à sa fin
donc ils sont bien plus crédible en tant
que médiateur que les etats-unis qui
n'ont aucun intérêt si ce n'est
d'instiguer à conflit entre la turquie
et la russie et
la turquie et l'iran donc air de gan
faut-il écouter
mike boom pow qui naissaient que de lui
causer des ennuis et qui en cas de
besoin ne sera pas là à ses côtés ou
souhaité il écouté les russes qui ont
aidé à faire de la turquie une puissance
régionale majeure et avec lesquels la
turquie à des accords et des intérêts
commerciaux très importants notamment
s'agissant des systèmes de défense ou à
des projets de gazoducs
donc tant que direction at il ce tout
mais je pense que air de gan part à
vouloir se tourner vers poutine pour
conclure
pour vous quelle est la solution
militaire finalement maintenant syrie je
ne pense pas qu'il y ait vraiment de
solution militaire qui permettent à la
turquie de gagner si la turquie essaye
de repousser les forces syriennes dans
la province d'idlib alors cela mènerait
à un conflit avec la russie et la russie
ne le permettra pas elle a été très
clair sur ce point il est temps
maintenant de mettre un terme à cette
guerre
les combattants à idlib doivent être
neutralisés par quelque moyen que ce
soit si la turquie se lance dans une
escalade essaie d'attaquer les forces de
damas alors il aura un conflit direct
avec la russie et la turquie n'a aucune
chance de remporter un tel conflit et au
niveau économique et géopolitique sur la
serait un désastre pour la turquie
merci beaucoup georges eu à me lis je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur au
global policy institute